the risks of regression to war in
post-conflict societies is high
when the government and the
international community
are not able to make strong efforts at
key moments
and sustain them over time
[Music]
when we took office
there was no electricity
and no
water schools and clinics have crumbled
roads were impassable
institution of governance had completely
collapsed
in july
of this year
we were able to turn on electricity and
water
to parts of our capital city monrovia
for the first time
in 15 years
[Applause]
[Music]
but time is pressing
or if our international partners
wait too long to ramp up its support
then we may lose the best chance liberia
has had in a generation
to end the conflict permanently
and build the foundations for growth and
prosperity
we cannot afford to let that happen
[Applause]
[Music]
liberians are resilient people
they just want the simple things that
most people take for granted
to live their lives in peace
get a good education
to be able to provide for their families
these things are not too much
for liberians to dream about
poverty reduction strategies
are at the core
of both averting a return to conflict
and establishing the foundation for
sustained development
we are placing emphasis on
empowering the people
especially the poor and vulnerable
to become participants
in a development process
education is central to renewal and
reconciliation
no nation can develop
under conditions of a 70 percent
illiteracy rate
liberia is not a poor country
but a country that has been poorly
managed
we are committed to change this
to pursue those goals that will move us
from christ from the crisis of the past
to the opportunity of the present
we are committed
as a people to build a new liberia
from the ashes of an old turbulent past
to a future
of hope and promise
thank you
you